that was a gun bros today we're checking
out get your nightmares that's right I
love this show I think I watched every
single one of the British ones they're
hilarious so today we're checking out by
Cyrus recommendation
an American wine what could go wrong
Laverne California just 30 miles from
Los Angeles this suburb is home to a
neighborhood Italian Bistro called
Charlie's and in 2010 it was bought by
the Leva family and so many Italian
restaurants I almost want March's
feedback on this to tell everything
wrong with it but I didn't have the
money or the collateral so I had to go
to my mom and my sister
no full-time School teachers Finance the
restaurant and put their houses up as
collateral no
don't do that they always do that
there's one thing I learned from
watching Gordon Ramsay is never start a
restaurant it seems awful they all get
tied up in a bunch of debt they don't
know how to fix it they're all just
miserable and their whole family's
involved it's just a night it's a
nightmare it's a kitchen nightmare my
mom and I don't know about the
restaurant business and so we put a lot
of trust in my sister's experience to
run the restaurant daddy maybe if you
don't have experience you should not
invest in
how many tables did you have Jen I only
had one
but look they got a tablecloth that
looks like and it matches the chairs why
we one thing Marty always says authentic
Italian restaurants will always give you
the the bread sticks the grissini I
don't see them it doesn't even pay for
the cost of just running electricity
who's gonna bring the people in I don't
know
before we continue quick word from
sponsor that's right we are back with
another Rhino Shield drop I know you're
thinking about doing your Christmas
shopping why not do it now I know you
have that one friend or yourself that
like PewDiePie because you're watching
this video right now Rhino Shield is
having the biggest sale of the Year up
to 60 sales the greatest time of year to
get the case you always wanted look at
the variety
we got the PewDiePie arcade looking nice
that PewDiePie rhyming they drink clear
case looking good
the Tokyo night combini version we also
brought back the old classic favorites
that you guys love I know you kids like
Hunter x Hunter I haven't watched yet
sorry but I heard it's good I know you
kids like Attack on Titan right okay
well Naruto your kids love Naruto all
right final deal you kids love dragon
ball pair it with a grip mini for the
extra tight security and as a hands-free
tripod you sloppy sweaty handers out
there I'm just kidding the classic wave
pattern is available in 20 plus
different colors get it exactly the way
you want it also don't forget to pair it
with their screen protector look I I
don't know how but I managed to actually
do it perfectly one thing I love about
Rhino Shield it's the customizability
you can change the buttons you can have
your name print then make the case truly
yours if I can do it you can do it thank
you Rhino Shield make sure to use my
code PewDiePie
my name and
you get 10 off you're welcome
I will expect a thank you
you're welcome and this 10 is addition
to the already sales on the website get
a gift for yourself or loved one thank
you Reiner Shield best phone cases
just keep watching video the problem
with the restaurant is
Tatiana
the fact that she feels like she doesn't
have to change things it's ridiculous
they don't like the service damn they're
ripping into the owner huh imagine like
15 years from now to completely run down
someone will do this video to me I'll
ask some popular YouTuber for help Mr
Beast please save this channel it comes
in sign has to sit down the problem is
he's a [ __ ] idiot I have to edit out
so much [ __ ] that makes sense
casimero is our head chef he's been here
for 14 years and he's pretty awful
it's a little chewier actually come on
that sounds dense
[Music]
when Tatiana manages the restaurant
usually that consists of standing around
with a glass of wine in her hand all
right so I was like he just drinks all
the time he's addicted to G feel he
snorts [ __ ] I have to edit it out I have
the CGI under his nose
so if we don't get more customers we
would lose our houses it is very serious
I really need Chef Ramsay's help so it
sounds like they're pretty desperate
right because a lot of times they just
they get Gordon Ramsay this world famous
chef to help them but they're not
receptive at all like they will not take
any advice and it always blows my mind
how stubborn these people are even
though like they have they have no other
choice like what else are you gonna do
which is clearly how they got in that
point to begin with
when she just walked in I just laughed
get yourself together your business is
[ __ ] you're not gonna be giggling for
long I know that because that's what I
don't know what to do with this nervous
energy and this anxiety how are you they
have customers
oh my God Tatiana yeah is uh is Charlie
in no he's not okay the Russian's called
Charlie who is he Charlie was the
original owner Charlie owned it Charlie
owned it how much money do you need to
get on the table before you took over
Mom put all her retirement money into it
no
a collateral
no oh
God can you imagine like I know
everyone's gonna be but you had many you
should give me I didn't always have okay
I can't imagine going to my parent like
Mom can you give up your pension because
I want to be a YouTuber why can't you
start small they always go all in it's
always Americans it's always American I
have a house on the line whatever who
cares I understand it works for some
people but for most people they don't so
maybe just like yeah it's the same it's
the same with YouTube everyone's like I
gotta have the best computer in the best
microphone because I want to be a
streamer and YouTuber you can just
start off you don't have to go all in I
don't know I don't know anything about
running a business but I watched enough
Kitchen Nightmares okay so where's the
restaurant goes it's your houses go
wow
um and how much money did you put in
um probably like a thousand bucks that's
it
okay financially where are we the
restaurant's been dead at this point
that's not good and who makes the
decisions here Tatiana well they have
other jobs as well so you have a
full-time job and you come in here to
run the restaurant right wow so what's
gone wrong then
you don't know
wow so then what's the changes you made
when you bought it
wow I can't believe it's not going great
I kind of want to do this with other
YouTubers like funny
trying to measure washed up YouTubers
and tell them they're what do you mean
you didn't ask for subscribers the first
five seconds what
you're trying you
for likes and subscribers immediately
but what if they don't want to watch
them or even trying
you have to bait them in to keep
watching the video with like a something
that's not that interesting but keep it
at the end so they keep watching but
but not interesting it doesn't matter by
the way guys surprised at the end of
this video You're Gonna Love it another
thing I don't think they trust me you
brought them into a mess what it comes
down to is that she does not treat us as
equals don't even start you talk down to
me you bulldoze me and you do not treat
me like an equal you don't treat me like
one-thirds of this restaurant well I
have the burden of the money and I make
and it's also like going into business
with your family which
seems nice on paper but like look how
miserable they all are like damn guys
don't don't do that let me see it don't
put your face don't put your house on
the line
there's always like the villain in these
shows and it's not always clear who the
villain is so far it's pointing towards
Tatiana all right he's gonna try the
food every time he tries the food he
hates it no matter what it could
actually sometimes look good but he just
spits that out okay
let's go
um right let's start off with the toasty
the fruit of the Mahoney
the lasagna it's not your typical
lasagna so be prepared for something
different
and I guarantee you the lasagna is
frozen and they're just gonna heat it up
which means something different
we're in California so why not some
chicken pizza how do you mess up a
lasagna and who makes the bread uh
casimiro or a head chef yes ready thank
you
[Music]
Red's Dreadful how do you mess up right
soggy yeah ew
do it toasted ravioli for the Chef
Ramsay I don't like any of the food so I
really you're the chef
we're the sous chef I don't know what
that I guess that means she does helps
which bits The Toasted bit yeah
I've recommended the ravioli I mean the
room yeah a lot of people don't like
that a lot of people don't like raw like
cardboard
oh she hates it
just let them be calm
why does she talk to the chef like that
that's okay
thank you
[Music]
it's also funny because like they know
they're cooking for Gordon Ramsay he's
getting the best version of the the
Polish turd right on top yes it is
can you put mozzarella on a fruta de
Mare
you can't do that she says she can't do
that what an idiot
well I can't take complaints to the chef
seriously I'm
really listen to any of us wow not good
the hell is that what's on here
[Laughter]
look at that that's a monster
the lasagna is vile it's embarrassing to
serve that to Chef Ramsay what's in the
sauce why is it that color it's pink
stuff she doesn't know what's a pink
sauce or lasagna is it his own recipe
yes it is
[Music]
and the mouthful I had oh God that looks
that actually looks disgusting just make
a lasagna just make a lasagna doesn't
make your lasagna it's hot one side cold
the other yeah I knew it it was frozen
it might be don't don't answer a
question you don't know oh
wow
um is there a problem with this
microwave it feels like the microwaves
on the blink yes it is wow when a
restaurant can't get food microwaved
properly still there's always hope for
the pizza it's actually looking nothing
like that all right all right they have
a sauna then Pizza it's crispy over
there
[Music]
where's my pizza garlic chicken yeah how
do you mess up a pizza oh God I hope he
likes something
sorry
oh bass Gordon Ramsay eats pizza with
knife and fork you are all wrong that's
how you eat a pizza thank you I rest my
Kings me and Gordon so pretty so dummy
and we've got all this raw pastry
underneath there oh no he doesn't like
the pizza it resembles
nothing homemade
how do you mix mess up a pizza that's
impossible it looks a little close to
Kay's kitchen cooking I'm sorry actually
never mind I take it back oh my God
you seriously have a kitchen
it's almost like we're on the show
have you watched the show would you know
what you sign up for yeah do you speak a
little English no no I
I'm upset I mean you have a really bad
depressing restaurants
this place is a mess
you know what it's not even mediocre
food is hideous but you don't need me to
tell you that for bread that's the kind
of bread that you're serving touch it
soaking wet it's bland and it's a
thousand miles away from anything called
Focaccia let me tell you that's the
[Music]
stuff that's Marcia's favorite brand she
makes a really good one
it's supposed to be soft and fluffy like
that I guess a little chewy
not like that pink lasagna stone cold in
the center piping heart on the right
hand side disgusting I just I trust them
so much I trust him
you can still try the food you can trust
someone but still be like all right I'll
try the food see if it's good
I love him do it yeah
what he was doing because he's been
doing it for so long no the problem is
he's got away with it for so long yes
with the overcooked Linguini in a
seafood dish no salt the shrimps solid
like a bullet yeah oh my God shrimp
shrimp is on bad restaurant I don't know
how many bad shrimps I've had I don't
know when look at this Mom
it's almost like chewy Swedish shrimp
good shrimp okay I have to tell you this
the best shrimp I have shrimp in UK it's
hard it tastes like rubber why do people
even eat shrimp in other countries I
don't understand it's disgusting sweet
and shrimp good shrimp bad shrimp chewy
show me ah
I mean Mamma Mia what a mess
I don't know
everything in my heart your heart is
frozen why did they do that one thing I
learned about running kitchen don't
froze the food don't do it Gordon Ramsay
will come in and be mad you can tell
when you eat it too I'm angry because
I've had this food you've had it too you
should be angry
angrier
it's okay
everything's frozen
meatballs do not defrost the meatballs
what is in this madness and I gotta say
Italians say you don't know how to make
a meatball
don't dislike video I'm joking come on
you have Italian meatballs you don't do
them good they just make meatballs you
have to mix the cream and the bread
crumbs and the bean your ham it tastes
much of better you can't have meatballs
with anything either we buying you
buying meatballs of course you can't
make a
meatballs
you speak in Spanish
they can't make a meatball he doesn't
want to look it is
oh wow can you make a meatball yeah my
hands are tight it's pretty hard
actually you take a thing
Italian food I learned from Italian wine
is so simple they always [ __ ] it up what
is that
noodles noodles how can you be an
Italian restaurant owner and you call
Pasta noodles that's illegal
Americans how much pasta does one Chef
need a lot of times
all overcooked can't you just wait so
they cook it oh my God so they cook it
and then they freeze it or uh what is it
called Kool-Aid it's 10 it's tenants you
just keep boiling water running not even
that if you have fresh pasta this is
just for the pizza not the bread
yeah yes
she came in there we're like okay it was
like how much stuff do you have Frozen
she's like what you want to see and
there's not enough time to prepare
everything with everything he has to
prepare in the day so what happens when
he doesn't sell this where does it go he
throws it away don't believe you I don't
believe what there are times where we've
thrown away a lot of pasta because
people aren't ordering it
no this is your house this is you this
is your life right here in the trash
Tatiana what I'm more concerned about is
the fact that you're oblivious I don't
know why you bought the place
and I certainly wouldn't pull my sister
down and bring my parents into it yeah
facilitate your ego dream yes he throws
what's the expression and like I look at
my mother and I feel horrible I feel
horrible excuse me don't start looking
for sympathy now yes I'm sorry it wasn't
your mother's dream it said it wasn't
Val's dream yeah or am I wrong
no it was tati's dream tati's dream
which is now come back to bite you on
the ass
what hurts me is that how you feel it's
what's gonna happen to them if this
doesn't work how's gone how's gone what
are you gonna do I don't know Gordon I
don't know but why did you do it
because I I thought I could make it
successful because I believed in myself
why not make changes
yeah how are we gonna make it successful
like keeping it the same idiot
[Music]
where you going
wow
what a joke he decides to make one
change right away okay
we're gonna make homemade meatballs I
want you to make me a meatball and I
want you to make me meatball I'd like to
say Shores I'd like to say shorts yes
later yeah yes
ah come on
I hate that when they chop I don't want
to taste onion pieces in my meatballs no
I like the taste of onion I don't like
that piece of onion in my meatball take
that [ __ ] away from me casamero
shouldn't have a problem since he's
working in an Italian it looks like
little zits in the meat am I the only
one
so
it's a hexbrew
he's not even frying them off because
the sauce
you have a pan frying pan
finish it off in sauce oh you don't know
that
no
excuse me
look at meatball I love that I'm better
than a chef that's been working for 20
years that's amazing
cat food
you cooking yours in a pan like you're
supposed to
[Music]
oh it's nice
okay soft yeah crumbling delicious I'm
gonna use them tonight they're going to
the menu tonight
you don't want the swimming meatballs
you're the sweet Chef
yes I get nervous when a chef can't even
make a meatball I mean honestly and this
young lady's flavor of her meatball 10
times greater
you're right darling yeah he just says
he wants to work slowly he wants to work
slowly why
because you're awesome
what an old crusty Chef customers want
to pay the chefs say I want to work
slowly are you kidding me no no no
[Music]
do restaurants normally just microwave
food that seems insane to me customers
find out I think the pasta is a little
overcooked it was definitely not worth
the wait Chinese food
yeah what the [ __ ] is that that looks
Chinese
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
oh come on I know I showed him how to
cut one off my back's turned to two
minutes and that's what I've got but
it's just stuck to a pan he turned
around Danielle hold on and said to
Danielle I've got uh I'm busy I can't
wash my meatballs that's what I'm gonna
work for what's Sean can play on the
meatballs they said it was like toasted
on one side but not toasted on the other
really how about telling your [ __ ]
chef
his house was on the line he wouldn't be
cooking like a [ __ ] idiot
[Music]
now he thinks it's funny
what do you want to do what he's not
gonna cook he doesn't want to cook
bro get that [ __ ] guy out of there I
feel like I don't know what I'm doing
here maybe I have no idea how to run a
restaurant oh wow you think no way wow
what what why high level of
introspection like you to believe that
the most impressive thing about kazoo
Mary's the fight he convinced people
he's an actual Chef for a year telling
me like I just don't have enough time it
costs at a time next stop and the other
dish you just sit there and you're
scared of that
I don't know why it's so refreshing
calling these people I am it's horrible
but they're going through and I feel
all the mistakes that he's made tonight
he doesn't take any direction he's
giving shove attitude he's he's the
problem
okay so it's the chef's fault now all of
a sudden
you haven't told him a single piece of
criticism for 20 years
yeah
okay
oh yeah
[Music]
[Music]
well I got depressing Jesus can they
turn it around come on Chef Ramsay is
now completely focused on rebuilding
Charlie's today is about moving forward
what we haven't got is somebody at the
helm someone's getting a promotion good
kitchen
I'd like to introduce you to someone
who's pretty unique Jonathan come
through
here
thank you now this man knows how to put
restaurants on the map more importantly
he's been working with me for the last
three years he's opened four restaurants
for the last five years you've got him
for the month I am oh wow thrilled we
have a chef it's like Christmas morning
I'm so excited I've never made it I
never made lasagna ever
that's crazy let's start off with mixing
take your white sauce nice and clean
with your fastest paper good
get close to it wait they don't even
make their own white sauce I need to
learn what needs to happen in a kitchen
and how it functions let's see two again
take your time I don't know why I
thought I couldn't do it it's not
difficult I'm telling you so you guys
just made pizzas they look so much
better than those pizzas and then
lasagna looks so much better I can do
anything oh my God I just can't wait to
get it's almost like it's not even that
hard
oh my God all right first of all we have
yeah simple clean menu right now let's
start off with a homemade focaccio bread
yeah yeah
salads we have the chopped salad in
there we've got garbanzo beans provolone
cheese salami finished with some fresh
and maltry lemon so it's got that really
nice oomph to it as well ah those are
meatballs those meatballs look
disgusting I prefer casamiros
okay the prosciutto pizza for Audrey on
the patio seven yes I'm doing cooking
right now okay I'm leaving them here
leaving them here with Tatiana stepping
up and organizing her staff talk to each
other Jen you're walking around everyone
is now in sync is it almost ready for
the prosciutto the prosciutto is ready
yeah this it's me lovers and entrees are
quickly making their way out to the
tables together and here's
pizza so good I know it's impossible
Captain America Society look way better
come on I'm proud of this restaurant now
I'm proud of it
thank you so much
you're very welcome all tickets are gone
Tatiana has finally stepped up and I'm
so proud to say that she's my boss
that's nice it was nice in the end but
will the restaurant make it thank you
I'm betting absolutely not because they
always [ __ ] it up it wasn't expecting to
be a perfect night let me tell you but
trust me overall it was successful
customers love the food and what you did
get an Insight tonight too was the the
potential of this place we can't give up
the foundation's here run with it yeah
yes good well done to you all have a
little word with you please
good night ladies after Gordon left I've
got the two stakes going okay so I'm
working this salad Chef Jonathan
maintained the high standards in the
kitchen is there anything you want me to
have the girls push right now
and immediately helped Jonah launch the
search for a new chef
thanks to her transformation not only is
her business back on track it's the
first Charlie's staff meeting
so is her relationship with her family I
owe Chef Ramsay like everything okay so
it actually turned out well I don't need
to be I almost don't believe it it's
gonna be like you've got it Tatiana yes
that was the worst British accent don't
ever do that again he was Spanish yeah
Cooks Italian food that tastes and looks
Chinese a man is a cultural
all right here we go
all right what happened
she became an actress but what happened
to casimiro oh no cancel mirror I want
to go to his restaurant it seems amazing
love a good Kitchen Nightmares I hope
you guys enjoyed as well smash like
subscribe what are you doing smash like
subscribe see you in the next one bye
bye